la question je pense qu'effectivement
cette réduction temporaire des libertés
ou abolition des libertés il ya déjà une
première différence les périodes de
crise on est période où effectivement la
population elle-même accepte un certain
nombre de restrictions mais je pense que
plus profondément il ya en effet par
rapport à la situation de la grippe de
hong kong en quelque chose qui a changé
c'est que pour le dire de manière un peu
mécanique au fur et à mesure que les
questions de salut déclinait je veux
dire la religion la question de santé
montait le salut a été remplacé par la
santé avec cette définition très
colossal de la santé je la rappelle par
l'om est sain la santé ce n'est pas
simplement l'absence de maladie mais
c'est l'état de plénitude bien-être
physique morale et sociale donc avec une
définition comme ça de la santé je veux
dire le risque de débordement du
sanitaire si je puis dire et évidemment
pas tant ça peut aller de partout le
salutaire tout est concerné tout
concerne le sanitaire avec cette idée
aussi que puisque nous n'avons plus de
choses on quand quelle on croit de
religion il vient nous allons avoir
effectivement l'hygiène la santé le
sanitaire qui va dicter nos règles de
vie et nono système est donc cette
montée en puissance du sanitat risme qui
accompagnent évidemment il faut pas le
nier des progrès colossaux dans
l'espérance de vie dont le traitement
enfin voilà les choses sont ambivalentes
mais cette montée en puissance du
sanitat risme c'est effectivement
quelque chose auprès de quoi on peut se
dire nous sommes prêts comme la religion
par le passé nous sommes prêts à
renoncer à un certain nombre de notes de
nos de nos libertés au nom de cette
nouvelle idole qui est en train de
monter en puissance et qui je crois ça
c'est un grand enjeu pour pour l'avenir
nous devons
trouver de quoi la critique et au sens
qu ancien du terme c'est-à-dire lui
poser des limites
où s'arrête effectivement le sanitaire
parce que ça n'a pas de fin la santé ça
n'a pas de fin moi même je crois je me
sens pas très très bien en ce moment
voilà je viens y en a pas il n'y a pas
de fin il n'y a pas de limite et donc il
va falloir vraiment trouver des limites
pour précisément faire en sorte que
l'équilibrage liberté santé se se fasse
disons dans une logique de bon sens et
non pas dans un délire qui peut être pas
tant
[Musique]